hello chess fans and welcome to a very
special Saturday afternoon broadcast
here at the beautiful st. Louis chess
club today we're going to be talking
about computer chess you know for the
past 20 years computers have outplayed
humans and were past that and we're
discussing something much deeper and fun
today hello my name is Ben Simon and I'm
joined alongside two very special guest
grandmaster Dennis burrows and of course
the computer chess expert you may not be
familiar with Jakob Wilkins Jakob
actually used to work at the club too so
we're all pretty close with each other
and we're here to talk about something
you guys feel passionately about alpha
zero and computer chess in general but
for those not in the know so far I have
to ask Jacob what is alpha zero why is
it so different from other computer
chess programs so alpha zero is
something that was released by deepmind
they released some results early in the
early results in December 2017 and
deepmind is google deepmind is a child
company of alphabet Google's parent
company so sort of their sibling
companies and they released a sort of a
preview of a paper that they were going
to publish in peer-reviewed journal and
they showed that they had used brand-new
techniques to beat stockfish which was
sort of head and shoulders the best
chess engine at the time okay and what
about this technique I mean we know that
chess engines they go over all these
different moves and they have opening
books
what makes alpha zero specifically
different from say Houdini or stockfish
so stockfish Houdini all of these
traditional engines at a very
fundamental level what they're doing is
they have a very simple and fast
evaluation so like when they determine
how good a position is that's very
simple but very fast and intentionally
so and then they just try to push their
analysis as deep as possible in the
important lines and they try to find the
absolute best position that they can
force so they don't they don't for
example look at how hard the line is or
how easy it is for their opponent there
is what is the best position I can force
and they've come up with a lot of clever
tricks to do this more effectively but
ultimately that's what they're doing
trying to look as deeply as possible and
figure out what is the best position I
can force Boris you actually did a
one-hour lecture here at the st. Louis
chess club not too long ago about how
you didn't think that alpha zero was the
best thing since sliced bread why is
that why are you a skeptic well I've
seen the first preview of which was
pretty astounding 27 wins for alpha zero
and seventy two draws with zero losses
but there were many in stock fish again
stock fish yes 17 yes one of the
strongest but there are many questions
open questions that were not answered at
the time and actually we are here to
talk about that with Jacob as as
Nakamura also mentioned they were things
like starfish needed opening books but
he didn't have one and he attributed
this big loss to that and I also felt
that there were some conditions that I
feel was not fair enough but I mean it's
also a good question if fairness is so
important to this match that's kind of
the question I you know partners for
jumping in it's so deeply so quickly I
mean we only have an hour but yeah if
alpha zero is playing against stock fish
in this big match and doesn't lose a
game how do you begin to dispute its
superiority over stock fish well the
thing is that I'm looking at is how did
the opponent fight so how did stock fish
actually amount against all four zeroes
game now for example I I saw a pellagra
have ski line went in the Queen's Indian
is well known where stock fish loss to
offer zeroes very nice attacking game in
d5 where stock fish didn't know
the exact way to defend now in that case
the lack of opening book I think was
crucial so in this sense I'm a bit of a
skeptic now
so you think stockfish was handicapped
without the opening book basically yes I
think so yeah now the opening book for
those of you who don't know I mean look
chess theory the openings are so widely
developed and so well known what moral
should saying is without an opening book
stockfish has to start thinking on move
1 which is basically it's not what chess
engines typically do this alpha 0 use an
opening book Jacob no so it in all of
these matches alpha 0 also did not have
an opening book the sort of the
counterpoint that a lot of people like
to say is because of how its trained
which will likely talk about in short
order it sort of effectively learns the
opening anyway so a lot of the initial
skepticism about these results are
published in the 2017 were pre print
those that was one of the big weaknesses
in the configuration people thought is
that alpha 0 has sort of implicitly
learned an opening book while stockfish
Justin didn't have one hey nowadays we
can download stock fish we can get chest
space we can put Houdini on that how can
i play on my computer with alpha zero so
you can't that's the the easy and
depressing answer so surprised yes
strangely deepmind has not released this
the nice thing though is that since
early 2018 there's been an open source
community driven project Lela chess that
has been basically trying to reproduce
the alpha zero results and they've had
astounding success for those of you
don't know there's a sort of a site
profile engine competition called TC EC
it's very it's on very high-end hardware
and it gets a lot of notoriety among the
computer chess community and broader
chess community and actually in about
two or three weeks they're gonna be
having the super final for this season
between the two strongest engines in
this season and that's actually going to
be stock fish and wila chests
little spectacular maybe but we can't
say that Lila chess is 100% the same as
alpha zero right yes
alpha zeros full specifications the
exact code that they wrote the exact
training parameters none of this was
revealed in full detail
so the Lila chess team has been sort of
going off the bits that have been
revealed and trying to get as close as
possible boorish I remember whenever
alpha 0 first those games will first
release you go to chest games.com you go
wherever and see the games that were
released and if I recall it was only
stock fish's win I'm sorry alpha zeros
wins that were released have the drawers
made it to see the light of day yet I
think so yes okay yeah so to add to that
so most of what we talked about here so
far were the results that were reported
in the preview paper or sort of the
reprint in 2017 the full peer-reviewed
paper has since been released that was
in December 2018 and in that they
released 210 games total a lot of
drawers and all and all of the losses in
in the particular matches that they
released
so we've now seen sort of the good the
bad and the ugly from alpha 0 and we'll
actually get to that a little bit of the
history here that's kind of crazy you
know Google is not just a search engine
anymore I'm sure if you've been reading
the headlines you know out the Alpha
name started with alphago right I mean
it's trying to be the best go plain
entity you've got the 19 by 19 board and
it's incredibly difficult for chess
engines I'm sorry for engines to be good
at I understand and well alphago
mastered that and then they go to alpha
0 which is speculated to be the
strongest chess playing entity in in the
universe and I just saw a few days ago
that alpha that deepmind is is making
its way into StarCraft and that was
interesting because Starcraft is not a
turn-based game and it was beating pro
players
where is deepmind going with all of this
what is next I mean man like it really
gets you thinking
yeah they they're clearly sort of trying
to push the limits of this reinforcement
learning learning from scratch to
conquer different domains it's not
exactly the same approach yeah they had
a very successful demonstration with
StarCraft
again a different approach but they've
also been trying their hands and things
like protein folding so sort of more
practical scientific endeavors so they
definitely have big plans it does seem
like is it it's is it here to stay that
was our main question and we can answer
already no it's under oh well yeah we
can definitely discuss that by the way
we are 100% live right now on the st.
Louis Chess Club YouTube channel and STL
chess club on Twitch and I do have your
comments open and we will be discussing
your questions if you have something
that would add to the conversation let
us know and st. Louis chess club on
YouTube and STL chess club on Twitch
okay guys so when we talk about alpha
zero and speculate whether it is the
greatest chess plain entity of all time
it's really impossible for us to know
for sure until the common man gets his
hands on alpha zero I mean do you agree
yes I do agree like you want to test it
out to actually feel what's happening
although there's a lot of information
getting out recently mostly the game
changer book by Matthew Sadler so
there's more and more information coming
out about the the monster itself but
actually training with it is something
that you want to do as a grandmaster but
as also as a side note we also heard
rumors that Fabiano did some training
with Lila chests preparing against
Carlsen I don't know if that's confirmed
or not but that's what I heard right
yeah you got to imagine that a lot of
the world's top players when
alpha0 dropped were like hey let me
throw you a few mil Google and deepmind
and let me get my hands on it I don't
think that happened yeah I mean even to
pallav previously tried to get get his
hand on on some computer technology but
after all the zero obviously everyone
wanted all fun right
Jakob Leela is alpha zero for the rest
of us can I add Leela chess on to my
computer at this time yeah absolutely
and it's available fairly
straightforward to download and download
the neural network that it which you
have a very large choice in it's a sort
of a one of the bigger if you can call
it a problem one of the bigger problems
is people are constantly trying to
figure out what is the strongest network
to use in but it's very straightforward
to download the engine download a
network and run it there are
instructions that are easily available
online so yeah it's definitely something
you can sort of load into chess pays to
analysis with all right I want to go to
the chatroom if that's okay yeah oh no
okay good
his you swinger it says I have an
important question who was moving
furniture in the background we are
underneath the kingside diner and they
are closing up shop so you're gonna be
hearing that all our and let's have fun
with it
next question from Jonas would giving
stockfish an opening book in a match
with alpha zero get stock fish only more
drawers or would it earn stock fish some
wins that's a good question I think
Jacob has an answer for that yes so one
of the one of the nice things about the
alpha 0 story is that as Dennis
mentioned earlier when they released
this preview paper in 2017 there were a
lot of conditions that people were a
little uneasy about to put it mildly
like the lack of an opening book the
time control was very bizarre for
computer chess it didn't a lot of stock
fish to use its sophisticated time
management you know the memory was
configured strangely in the full paper
which was released in December 2018 they
actually included results of a match
against stock fish news
a book the book is called cerebellum and
it's a book based on deep stockfish
analysis and to answer the question
directly in that match you sort of see
both stock Tricia's score improved it
didn't really get any more wins with
black but with white it actually started
to score some wins it's still lost of a
match fairly clearly the performance
rating for alpha zero was something like
plus 52 stockfish in that match but it
definitely performed better managed to
pull off some wins with the white pieces
but it wasn't enough to bridge the gap
are there any main weaknesses or blind
spots in alpha 0 or Leela that we can
deduce so far that compared to other
chess engines yeah absolutely so it's
sort of the result of its big strengths
as well so the way it's searched and the
neural network work together it's very
it's very much looking for positions
where it has a lot of good options and
sort of the practical results that think
favored it and in doing this it's sort
of averaging values over a lot of
positions it's not like traditional
engine saying okay I have a forced
sequence this one line gives me this
evaluation so that's what I'm going for
it's taking into account like well what
if I mess up what if my opponent messes
up its averaging in these suboptimal
lines that's great for sort of playing
these long-term strategic align its off
a zero and allele are so impressive at
but this sort of averaging approximate
evaluation also makes it susceptible to
very precise very concrete lines which
you see in some very complex tactical
positions and you see them a lot of
times in end games where you have some
sort of counterintuitive very precise
line that you need to play and their
Leela and alpha zero both shows some
fairly clear if hard to exploit
weaknesses isn't that a lot like poker
kind of thinking for computers because I
know that in like even in poker you have
percentages of chances of you playing
the right cards and winning or just
getting the right cards and therefore
the percentages the chances of you
winning the match changes dramatically
is that something similar what alpha is
doing the concept is similar like it's
taking into account things that might
not be optimal so traditional engines
say just say assume best play by both
sides one musician results that's all I
care about
I don't care what happens if either of
us makes a weird mistake what they're
doing is you have more playing the odds
it's like okay like what what would I
choose if I assume that there's some
chance for both me and my opponent to go
wrong which it sort of implicitly does
so in some ways yeah it's similar
obviously it's different in that there's
no actual on there are no unknowns in
the game of chess it's all there I'm
like poker but the concept is sort of
similar it's playing the odds I mean I
would disagree a little bit that it's
all known because even in chess there
sometimes there are situations when you
have like five equally good options
right and it's not always clear which
one to choose from now when let's say
alpha or Leela is pitted against a
different computer what would normally
happen in this situation when there's
like equal opportunities like five very
similar moves and they have to decide
correctly which computer would be
favored so though in those sorts of
situations Leela and alpha zero will
typically handle those much better
because for a traditional engine like
stock fish Houdini or Komodo just
elicits the sort of the top three like
they will if they're all zeroes with
best play they're just going to pick one
all those zeros meaning totally drawn
right you're sort of the dreaded you
plug this into your chess engine you're
like oh I think I'm better here and it's
just like 10000 the tactics force draw
in a lot of positions traditional chess
engine just gives 0.004 several lines
here traditional engines tend to just
sort of pick one and move
whereas Lila chess alpha0 they're better
able to say okay yeah maybe but best
play this is equal but which ones give
me more chances which one give my
opponents more chances to mess up so
they tend to play those in a much better
way and actually in you mentioned this
book earlier it was released yesterday
Matthew Sadler's book on office zero he
actually has an entire chapter talking
about this phenomenon where in many of
the games stockfish is giving 0.004
several moves several times in a row in
a sequence and that's where it starts to
get into trouble because it's just like
it doesn't matter where as alpha zero is
well let me steer this to the heart or
drama and it eventually gets too hard
even for stockfish
Jacob we have a question from BW 12:35
he says how do we determine what size
neural network is needed to capture the
necessary complexity of chess can
information theory tell us how much can
be stored in a specific configuration of
neural net so that's an interesting
question that doesn't have a clear
answer it's you could you can run some
numbers and you know sort of make some
assumptions and come up with something
but it really depends on what you mean
by capturing the complexity of chess if
you just mean to play it's sort of the
highest practical level that's hard to
say but it's going to be a lot smaller
than if you mean to play perfect chess
if you mean to get similar results to
say a 32 piece table base it's unlikely
that a neural net would sort of in
anyone's lifetime get to that sort of
level but just to sort of tie this into
the way things are the current strongest
nets from Leela are a 20-block 256
filter Network and that's a compress
that's about 50 Meg's so they're already
playing world-class level in a neural
net that you know takes up about 50
Meg's on your on your disk which is
quite small and for those of you who's a
lot a lot of that went over
I'm there with you Boros just to clear
this up yeah you are not against the
idea of alpha zero you simply feel it is
unproven right yes I kind of wanted
explanations for that first match I'm
interested if it was kind of fair or not
I'm not saying it's necessarily unfair I
just raised points that okay stockfish
didn't have or allegedly didn't have
enough time to make the right move that
was needed
also I raised the same issue as was
mentioned even in the paper that the
opening book was really missing for that
match do you do you feel like it would
be more legitimate if stockfish
programmers or representatives were
present to negotiate for this match yes
definitely that would help even more
okay well I understand that you guys
have some positions you want to look at
that will bring some discussions up for
debate
so Boros what do you have to show us so
far so I want to show two games actually
so even in the book which is called game
changer and they say that alpha zero
changed the way the view chess and to be
honest I'm not sure that entirely the
case and I'll show you why so actually
I'm not gonna show this one first but
the other game false alarm yes this one
so we're going through the bot vinik
tall game which is interesting for a
different reason now many people say
that in the 1960s they didn't know how
to play chess that's false namely tall
will show a chest that will remind you
of the brilliancy of alpha zero there's
a mode that's activated it's pretty
arrows on the screen
do we know how to get rid of those is it
training up here training I think that
is cool
93 I'm fast forwarding to that moment so
we get to this point and here so the
something that obviously been done
before million times people sacrifice
make combinations and such but this is a
world championship match and that
usually changes the dynamic in general
and when tell played this sacrifice this
was unheard of how come one sacrifice is
a piece for nothing
obviously not nothing this Bishop will
open up and there's lots of lots of
pressure on White's position now it's
interesting to see that our first
thought is what is this you're giving a
piece away for free well because of this
why does being imbalance here and he
makes one normal-looking move takes Ruby
Von f3 and he's already in huge trouble
and even though tall miss Knight f4 move
Knight might not be the most accurate
one it's still a new chapter of meaing
very practical and it turns out one of
the best decisions in the position so
just like I want to compare this to this
computer world like we have iPads iPods
but we wouldn't have in none of them
without phone Norman who invented the
basic computer so that's why I'm saying
that even though tall's combination
might not be perfect but the concept
what he's doing here is shown in many of
the games these computers play I
remember during the lecture you were
saying alpha zero is just like mikkel
tall
yeah okay so I mean is there follow-up
to this I mean what what is is your
assessment complete yeah this is my
assessment that I feel that tall's game
is kind of a precursor to these engines
of playing these more aggressive play
more practical play and looking at that
as something much stronger Jacob what do
you have to say about that yeah this
this I think is all quite correct this
way of playing for humans has not been
as you say like this is nothing new
right playing for practical chances you
know looking saying okay maybe these are
all sort of objectively leading to the
same result with perfect play but lets
me do let's make the move that gives my
opponent the most problems this is
nothing new for humans the interesting
thing with alpha zero
wila and this sort of approach is that
computers are playing sort of this way
now where where it's not just oh I see
that with perfect play this all leads to
the same thing let me just pick some way
of playing it's actually like okay let
me pose problems for my opponent let's
make things easier for me can't even
compare this to the office zero game
that was played again stockfish recently
and this one is this game yeah by
recently was this in the original
matchers it's different this is the
newest matches far okay I know yeah this
is yeah this is one of the games that
was released with the 28 disagree 18 to
20 18 in that chamber yes so I'm
following your take so we're playing
this regular Dutch defense which just
for the average viewer one of Chomsky's
favorite who's a multiple US Champion
and like rugby one this looks like a
weird move but it's actually preparing
this
idea of beef b4 and b5 now that's why
black stops it with a 5 Queen b3 which
actually looks funny and I feel that
there's some opening books involved here
this would be money 5 must be still
theory 9 a 6 rook d1 this looks all
normal h6 already feels like an offer 0
idea
Bishop e3 I actually go up to the
critical point rook c1 and to be honest
here I'm kind of critical that stock
fishes play usually white would strive
to do some heavy structure structural
damage to black before it's too late but
in this game stock fish kind of plays
very slowly with very little planner at
least I couldn't really decipher what
white was doing here Bishop d7 c5 okay
now I would get that they want to do
some damage to Black's position but then
slowly white comes up with this Bishop
d2 Bishop II 1 moves and I'm not quite
sure what white is doing but black as
you can see has a plan already we routed
the knight from a 600 bit if either is X
to the 5 and all of the black pieces are
coming to life Queen e8 planning this
classical g5 Queen h5 plan
III g5 and actually that's kind of
interesting because maybe even h4 could
be considered if you know what black is
already planning to do but anyway c3 g5d
to ship f3 just fast forward there and
here comes Knight g5 and this is
something that whenever I first looked
at this game my first thought was oh
this is Botvinnik tal all over again
yeah in this this is actually very
interesting because if you look at this
position with stock fish right it takes
in a very long time to realize the 95
even playable and to sort of give props
to the Leela team for sort of faithfully
being able to get something in the
ballpark of alpha0 with Leela chests
with one of the recent neural networks
it settles on Knight g5 as early as like
80 positions evaluated so by the time
it's calculated 80 positions it's
already like yeah yeah 95 is good on
planes so for the average human being
what does 80 position mean in time so
first for Leela depending on your
hardware 80 positions even on like the
slowest is probably going to take you no
more than a few seconds oh wow on the
very fastest this is going to be
instantaneous whereas like stockfish
even on a decent computer takes a very
long time to even consider that 95 is
playable mhm I have a question on top of
a question here from our chat from
Christian philosopher any Alekhine's
game any alkynes defense games by alpha
zero I actually wanted to kind of up the
ante there from alpha zeroes play
without an opening book is there
anything that we have learned that the
chess community has learned thus far on
existing openings anything that's faulty
anything that is better than we once
thought or did we just have it all
figured out or we can't figure it out at
all so it's a sort of in-between and
this is a recurring theme Dennis and I
have talked about this and private as
well sort of a recurring theme with
alpha zero especially is that you get
these sort of sort of binary opinions
like either you know it was all sort of
a marketing ploy and doesn't mean much
or it's you know like God descended from
on high to play chess with us the truth
as so often is somewhere in the middle a
lot of what we see in alpha zero is play
in various openings is stuff that would
be familiar to any Grandmaster right
it's playing in a very high level but
the ideas are not necessarily always you
know you know a thunderbolt from one
high like there's stuff that a
grandmaster would recognize is being
high
that's one of the ideas now this is not
to say that it's contributed nothing so
again sort of to continue with this
theme we'll mention the book game
changer by Sadler released yesterday he
actually has a section on how officer
handles the opening and one of these
investigations is actually there's a
typical structure in chats called a
carlsbad structure are usually arriving
from the queen's gambit declined
exchange variation and alpha0 does
handle this quite a bit differently than
most from humans do it basically ignores
the idea of a minority attack altogether
and plays the position in a very
different way so in many positions it's
sort of just implementing old ideas and
sort of a more vigorous way and other
times it actually is contributing some
some new ideas very well Boros were you
surprised pleasantly by anything that
alpha zero had to offer in the released
games well it was still kind of a new
thing to see a computer play so
aggressively and so excitingly I haven't
seen huge novel ideas what I did
appreciate especially this relentless
attacking chest that is rarely seen in
computers so actually I'm looking
forward to more matches when you
actually see the incubating phase when
you see alpha zero play against alpha
zero or even Leela chess against Leela
chess from a combative position so
that's something that I would be very
excited to see I mean I would be excited
to see a stage zero alpha zero versus
alpha zero right yes well what in the
world would you even see if it has no
opening books supposedly nothing but
knowledge of the rules right yeah I mean
that's got to be fun to watch it's gonna
be crazy
birth birth computer Grand Master yeah
and we do we do kind of see this with
Leela so with Leela right it develops in
sort of the same way source starts from
start from effectively random play and
then it improves and at each stage to
determine whether that this current
network is not a not bugged it plays a
match against the previous one and the
games from these matches are available
like you can look at them online and so
you can actually see sort of like how it
plays along its development because it
does start from effectively random
random play and yeah it some of them are
quite humorous someone in our chat
earlier asked if alpha zero could beat
Carlsen I think that any chess engine
now it's pretty much a parent it can be
the strongest human player in 2019 but
you have a comparison to Carlsen I
understand a position was that you or
was that you it's from the game from
Carlsen good at Carlson Caruana yes yes
I mostly have something very interesting
about computer thinking so this game let
me go up this was actually the last game
that Fabiano played against Carlsen the
third rapid yes the third rapid and so
there's many many very strong computers
out there there's office 0 there's Leela
chess and also there's sesor so when we
were looking at this position at the
assemblies chess club while they were
watching the match Sesa showed three
good equally good options and now I just
really want to point this out how a
grandmaster would think and how a
computer would thing now the sets a
computer said you put the rook here you
put the rook here or god forbid you put
the rook on f8 I don't really care it's
the same deal now it's very interesting
because if you would put the rook on f8
and you would go to any super
grandmaster and say I want to become a
chess player in my suggestion
is look from a 8 to f8 I think you're
immediately dismissed because and it's
not that it's bad but humans like to
think ahead and rook F fate is just
putting a bad piece to worse place now
the computer might think and could be
correct at the same time and it changes
nothing but as humans be very
uncomfortable from to make a bad bad
piece go even worse so it's no wonder
that Bobby played rook e8 and then even
later went rogue d8 and actually I think
this is one of the strong sides of the
humans is that we anticipates sometimes
1015 moves ahead what is going to happen
like white is not forced to play e5 here
but when we're looking at this position
our main concern with black is that e5
is going to happen maybe not in two
moves but in 10 15 moves definitely and
guess what even in the game a 5 happens
and that's how cause them won the match
yeah and in general what you know what
you said is true
quite quite correct is that this goes
back to the sort of the zero zero zero
wins made earlier right with traditional
engines they have a hard time if as far
as they can tell with best play
everything and similarly they have a
hard time picking which is again an
advantage of this sort of approach that
alpha zero and lelee use where it's not
just all about like okay well what
happens with absolutely best play it's
like well what gives me the most options
in case things go a little bit
differently like what if what if I make
a suboptimal move my opponent makes a
suboptimal move and it's then that you
start thinking you're sort of more like
a human although you know sort with a
machine level of precision where you're
like okay well let me put my piece here
just in case these other things happen
even if they're not ideal would there be
like a value system that would benefit a
computer because I feel that even this
one could
the statistics could be a value that
okay I will value the squares as well
and say that if I'm moving my rook to
even more closed file that's like a
minus value and just plus it up or it
just takes too many values to so stop
like traditional engines like stock furs
already definitely do things like that
like they they sort of penalize pieces
for being on worse squares get them
bonuses for being on better squares the
trick Israeli like they're pushing this
analysis fairly deep and they're not
caring about like where the piece goes
in the middle of the line they're just
looking at okay with best play at the
end of the line which is the position
look like and if they all end in the
same way after a bunch of shuffling they
don't care what happened in the meantime
and so that's sort of the thing is like
it's not looking at the position after
rook FA it's looking at the position you
know 20 moves in the future and saying
okay buy 20 moves in the future it
didn't matter that my rook navigated to
f8 and then back somewhere else so they
definitely already have bonuses and
penalties like this it's just they don't
care about you know like well what if my
rook stays on f8 they don't they're like
well I'm gonna move it away later so it
doesn't matter
so actually ya know talking about values
you mention one of the games where
actually off of zero wins very nice game
where actually values plays a very high
role zero English game now I want to
stop here for a second I noticed many
commentators said that Oh Queen b6
whatever stock fish made a move again
it's something like the rook f8 thing
here grandmasters if anyone would ever
dare to suggest Queen b6 we would frown
and we would point at the door because
the main concept of white is that I want
to play d4 here I want to open up the
position now you can stop me as black
from playing d4 but Queen b6 is
something that you know if we're talking
about humans is naive it's saying that
oh you're going to play d4 and then we
transpose back to the main line open ott
queen d4 but Knight takes d4 and then we
transpose back but obviously what is not
not going to do any of this and then
Queen b6 is just very silly here this
queen is just silly here so I I'm not
saying that Queen b6 is losing but even
when you analyze games sometimes
grandmasters even say that the last and
the first mistake was Queen b6 and that
was the cause of the downfall and I feel
that it's not fair to point out that
this game wasn't even from the get-go
this game was advantageous to offer 0
maybe not too advantageous but
advantageous nonetheless with this Queen
b6 move as that's in the way but what do
you have to say about that yeah and this
is sort of again like going back to that
recurring theme that as long as a
traditional engine sees that with Best
Play things sort of end up in a similar
place it has a hard time distinguishing
among them especially if it thinks that
there is nothing better than to
transpose to some normal line so this
position is a decent example even the
current we bring the board back ok just
a second even the current stock fish
while it doesn't play Queen b6 here it
sort of does it by accident right like
it's not that it sees that Queen b6 is
somehow worse or substantially worse
it's sort of just it's like something
else slightly better so it avoids it but
if you force Queen b6 it still thinks
everything's kind of ok and again you
know the closest thing that we the rest
of the world have to alpha 0 is Leela
and Leela does get substantially happier
why'd evergreen v6 it has to your point
it probably should because this makes
blacks job harder maybe you know maybe
with perfect play it's all the same but
it's still you set yourself a harder
task so you're kind of saying that maybe
Queen b6 is not a mistake if you play
5000 beautiful and precise moves right
yeah and that's sort of the the risk
traditional engines run and it's what
you see in some of the games where they
end up losing to alpha zero or you know
we also have games were stock fish or
other traditional engines lose Dalila
and this happens a lot where they're
playing and they're like okay yeah this
is fine this is fine this is fine and
they're not necessarily wrong with
perfect play maybe they do still draw
these games but they've sort of painted
themselves into a corner where now they
have to play perfectly and as strong as
they are stockfish comodo who do you
need these engines are still not playing
perfectly so it still affects them if
they paint themselves into a corner
where they have to play incredibly
precisely kind of going with this
percentage chest that maybe this is
still correct in the realm of acceptable
and it's still not something that you
should reject totally but
percentage-wise white is slightly
happier
right exactly like there's you know
white gets a little more leeway black
gets a little less leeway you and I
talked a little bit earlier like I think
a good comparison here is like for a
traditional engine like especially if
you're using table bases right like you
know from the perspective of the table
base there's no difference between
defending a drawn King and pawn verse
King ending and defending king and rook
first king or a can bishop from a table
based perspective as long as you start
in a drawn version of one of them
they're both just draws however in
practical play if you're not a table
base you definitely should have some
preference of one over the other
and while it's not quite that black and
white with something like stockfish
versus alpha zero or size versus lela
they run a similar risk where they're
like well if I play perfectly for the
next so long then it looks like
everything's okay but as good as they
are they're still not playing perfectly
so it does still matter
you know they get steered into something
that's a little bit harder a little bit
harder and then eventually it's even
beyond their capabilities which are
astronomical but you know they are
following yes so I want to continue with
this game a little bit because this will
actually be important if we're still
talking about values and how the
computers measure things age for clearly
off of zero is getting ready to push
that hairy pong up up there Bishop d6 h5
Queen d8 and now whenever I was learning
chess from older grandmasters they would
point with their old finger at the Queen
on d8 and says why did you move your
Queen to b6 if you ten moves later moved
back to d8 what is wrong with you
and obviously that's a bit harsh because
sometimes you have to make the best move
possible but it's also a warning sign
and that's why I like older grandmasters
point this out frequently is that if you
move your piece and then you have to
move it back probably something went
wrong and then here comes the h6 move
and something you had some something to
say about this age six yeah guarding
this match yes so this is actually
something that people in the Leela
community or people who have been
following we live for a long time
they'll start recognizing and getting
pretty diddy about Leela loves to do
this with its pawns and it turns out
alpha zero as well there's actually
again an entire chapter about this in
game changer by Sadler
so alpha zero and Leela are very similar
they light they love to get this
cramping pawn on the square like h6
where it restricts the King sets up
potential mating threats like even in
end games where there's not immediate
mating threats they like they both Leela
and alpha zero really love this
formation they get they get very excited
like usually the evaluations become very
high they're willing to do this even
often for the cost of a pawn or two
mm-hmm yeah I remember facing these h4
h5 h6 ideas when I was really young and
I also was as skeptical as stock fish
that all nothing's gonna happen what do
you want
and actually my bishop was already
fianchettoed so on this diagonal and
it's still it can get stuck in this
corner on h8 and it does and it does
nothing for like 15 moves and it
obviously I lost that game because that
Bishop on a Jade is just terrible and
what's kind of interesting is that the
more experience you get the more you
appreciate like these values you think
that that's just a pawn on h6 but the
more experience you get in this game you
realize it's it's something that should
be valued I remember Kasparov saying
that if there's a knight on f5 it's
worth a rook which might be a little bit
exaggerated but usually when you get a
knight on f5 this specific square which
obviously is defended now but if that is
not attacked then you have a firm
attacking Knight on f5 usually you get a
huge attack and you might even vend
material and I wonder like are there is
there some loopholes like that still in
computers like not appreciating that one
piece occupies a square and that's just
so important yeah and this particular
theme no this is actually a good example
of precisely that in many of the leela
stockfish games that we've seen in chess
comms computer Chess Championship and in
TCC this sort of thing this thorn paw
and as people of flint start calling it
this this has been a common theme in
games where stock fish has sort of
struggled and so there the stock fish
team has actually already like
introduced a patch where they give this
sort of pawn a fairly high bonus and
this has actually made stock fish a
little better so there's already these
sorts of
instead of been you know sort of
revealed by playing against new types of
engines like alpha zero and we love now
Jacob you said they released stockfish
released a patch the idea one of the
ideas behind alpha zero is it should not
need a patch the way that it learns is
that right
I mean you can add a very very high
level you can sort of view it is like
self patching in a way the trick though
is that you can't easily direct it like
you know in this case with stockfish
they were like ah this is a pattern that
stockfish undervalues let's you know
introduce some code to sort of fix that
with something like Lela or alpha zero
there's no such explicit guidance and
what it learns it plays itself and it's
kind of a black box what it's learning
when what it's learning to represent and
value you just have to hope it keeps
getting better any further points to
make on this particular game I'm just
showing the last moment of the game
where stockfish gave up and you can see
that that h6 spawn both the h6 spawn and
the f6 spawn are like a Fang holding the
black king captive and there's no way to
stop that C pawn from marching in and
cleaning this was a very nice game
although as Jacob said big trouble
started with three foreign accuracies by
black one of them is bringing the Queen
out way too early then going back that's
actually losing a lot of time then
losing a bit of the bishop there that
fissure would be like be going crazy
here and also allowing this h4 h5 h6
idea and this was just too much now I
went through the end part but it was
very interesting also to see that there
there's been a lot of dilly dallying
with the pieces is that because it's a
closed position or sometimes they just
feel that I don't need to do anything
special it's just it's just equally good
so I just play it yeah
this is sort of a well-known thing
especially in these close positions in
traditional engines especially if they
think their positions good maybe they
think their positions good for some
static reason and they'll just move
around and avoid avoid rocking the boat
right they're just like oh I like the
way my position looks I'm gonna keep it
there and so you'll see a decent number
of come high level computer games or one
engine thinks this and they'll just move
around for 35 40 moves and then they're
like oh if I keep my position looking
pretty like this there's a 50 move draw
and then so they'll make some concession
like they'll push a pawn or trades and
pieces and then repeat so yeah this is
not unusual for high-level computer
chess all right well thank you very much
for that that demo right there Jacob
will page in our chat has asked what our
deep minds intention specifically is
alpha zero continuing to be developed
and improved so not surprisingly the
boring answer to that is unfortunately
for me I don't work for deep mind so I
can't really say for sure
however the indications that we've
gotten from some of the communication
that we've seen one of the one of the
guys on the team has actually generously
answered questions on one of the big
computer chess forums it seems like they
are probably continuing to do some work
with it but this is far from certain we
don't really know but I suspect they're
probably still putting some time into it
borish if let's say that alpha zero
eventually gets released to the public
the lay man can get his hands on alpha
zero I think that alpha zero has built
up such a mystique right now based on
what people don't know for sure that if
it was ever released people would look
at this as it's like the god of chess
right and my question for you is is
there any way that this could hurt chess
as far as humans play is there anything
to be afraid of
actually I have kind of an example of
how computer chess hurts your game oh no
so
getting into a little bit of weaknesses
and this time especially human
weaknesses so recently as many of you
know in the Tata Steel tournament
Shanklin resigned a drawn position now
obviously that sadly sometimes happen
but I think there's something related to
using computers too much so he knew a
technical position at the end and he
resigned then he needs to corner his
King and computers like traditional
computers that we use usually give you
one line which is George and doesn't
give you many options of drawers so
you're looking for the one specific
solution so when Shanklin decided oh I
can't put my King in the corner
therefore I must be lost and that's
probably a reason he resigned because he
didn't believe anymore that he's going
to hold the position and it turns out if
he would have believed that there's more
than one solution to the position
probably he would have found the draw as
he didn't need to put his King right in
the corner but could have kept it closer
to the Queen side well gentlemen it's
been a fun hour so far and we are
nearing the end unfortunately but I'd
like to give both of you an opportunity
to give your final points Jacob you go
first
what's your take over all on alpha zero
is it here to stay
yeah put that way I think the only
answer really can be yes the techniques
used by deep mind and off zero have been
very successfully even with a little bit
of information that was revealed it's
been very successfully reproduced by the
Leela team who was already performing at
a very high level and influencing things
like analysis so I'd say the easy
answers the simple answer is clearly yes
all right
Boris what's your final take on alpha
zero and what we've talked about this
hour well it was very eye-opening to
talk with jacob cuz i use the computer
mean only to use the computer to
understand the game better
I appreciate off of zero more now
especially that there's more and more
papers released I I think that part of
it especially I think Lila will stay mmm
what I feel is that alpha0 will look for
even more grounds to conquer that's what
I see right now well one thing is for
certain even though we are humans we use
computers and I think everyone can agree
that human play is changed it is
significantly altered we learn from
computers and it's an exciting time to
be around the game of chess I want to
tell all of you about some big upcoming
events here presented by the st. Louis
chess club as you know the Karen's Cup
the first annual Karen's Cup is just a
couple of weeks away round one is
February 6th we are gonna have 10 of
some of the best female players in the
world for the first time here in st.
Louis they're going to be playing in a
round-robin event in the style of the
Sinquefield Cup so we are going to have
English commentary we will have Russian
commentary right here in Studio B here
at the st. Louis Chess Club also you can
watch that at us chess champs calm just
yesterday the format for the 2019 grand
chess tour was announced and it is the
biggest one ever while there was a press
release that went out one month ago this
time we know specifically what will
happen the st. Louis rapid and blitz
it's happening we're also going to be
adding the cote d'ivoire
rapid and blitz invitational and another
classical event in croatia so that's
gonna be just like the Sinquefield cup
this is gonna be an amazing year for
chess guys and it all begins in May on
the Ivory Coast for more information on
that gram chest tour org the information
will be up there shortly and right now
you can visit grande chest or on
facebook for the press release and the
you'll schedule so that's gonna do it
for this hour here in Studio B we've had
a great conversation about alpha zero
this event was directed by the world's
greatest B team right now he's his own
one-man show Danny would chuka is your
technical director thanks for joining us
Jacob it's been great talking with you
sir let's go Josh good talking with you
Grand Master Dennis barouche and Jacob
Wilkins I'm Ben Simon until next time
for the Karen's Cup we say so long from
the show-me-state